Envie de neige ?
Ça tombe bien, pour la deuxième classe grandeur nature,
je vous emmène sur les pentes enneigées.
On va retrouver une classe de neige
et on va découvrir
des activités que l'on peut pratiquer
à la montagne en hiver.
Bon, et puis vous me connaissez un peu.
On va en profiter pour faire
un peu de science, de la physique.
Il y a un tas d'expériences à faire à la neige.
Tiens, on va même construire un igloo.
Ça vous tente ?
Enfin, un igloo hein, pas une tente.
Après les volcans d'Auvergne,
nous voici dans le massif du Vercors,
dans le département de l'Isère,
au sommet de la Sure précisément.
Alors ce ne sont pas vraiment les Alpes, plutôt les Préalpes.
Juste devant moi,
le massif de la Chartreuse,
dans le creux, blottie sous les nuages,
la ville de Grenoble que l'on surnomme
la capitale des Alpes.
Les Alpes, justement, commencent
juste derrière,
avec la chaîne de Belledonne
et tout à l'opposé,
on en profite parce qu'il fait un temps très très clair,
le magnifique massif du Mont-Blanc.
C'est beau, hein !
On n'est pas venu ici que pour admirer le paysage.
La classe de neige,
c'est l'endroit idéal pour découvrir et s'initier
à la pratique du ski alpin,
du snowboard ou du ski nordique.
Ce qui permet de découvrir
la multitude des sensations de glisse.
Alors ces disciplines
sont très facilement accessibles,
surtout en classe de neige où les élèves sont encadrés par des moniteurs.
Et quel que soit le niveau de l'élève,
il y a toujours une piste à sa hauteur,
ce qui permet d'apprendre, de s'initier
en toute sécurité.
Alors ces pistes sont
facilement reconnaissables,
ça dépend de la couleur.
Bleu, facile, rouge, difficile et noir, très difficile.
Je viens d'arriver, je vais y aller mollo.
Bleu.
Allez, c'est parti !
Piste verte, facile.
Ah ! Je vous avais promis un peu de physique, pas d'activité hein, de science.
J'ai une petite question à vous poser. Sur quoi glissent nos skis ?
"De la neige" me direz-vous.
Eh bien non, c'est faux, nos skis ne glissent pas sur la neige.
La neige est un solide.
Nos skis également.
Quand on pose deux solides l'un sur l'autre,
les frottements sont très importants.
S'il n'y avait que de la neige,
nos skis ne glisseraient pas.
En fait, nos skis glissent sur l'eau,
une fine pellicule d'eau.
Il ne s'agit pas de ski nautique.
Quand le ski glisse sur la neige,
il génère des frottements qui produisent de la chaleur.
Il se forme alors une petite pellicule
d'eau qui va servir de lubrifiant
et permettre aux skis de glisser sur la neige.
Attention, je parle de ski, ce ne sont pas des palmes.
S'il y a trop d'eau, on est confronté
à ce que l'on appelle l'effet ventouse.
C'est pour cette raison que les skis
doivent être très bien préparés.
Allez ! Suivez moi, on va voir ça.
- Bonjour Florent.
- Bonjour Jamy.
Alors Florent n'est pas en train de repasser un ski,
il est en train de déposer une fine
couche de fart.
Qu'est-ce que c'est exactement ?
Alors le fart c'est comme de la bougie,
c'est comme de la paraffine.
C'est quelque chose qu'on va chauffer, qu'on va déposer après.
C'est pour ça qu'on utilise comme un fer à repasser pour le faire fondre sur la semelle.
D'accord, ça se présente comme ceci.
Comme ceci, tu peux l'avoir en pain.
- Oui !
- Tu fais goutter directement avec le fer.
Ou autrement, les paillettes,
on les met dans une casserole
qui permet d'avoir l'imprégnation complète de la semelle.
D'accord, on la fait fondre et puis on dépose sur la semelle.
Et cette paraffine a la particularité d'être hydrophobe.
Comme son nom l'indique, elle n'aime pas l'eau.
On va faire une petite expérience.
Ici, on a un ski qui n'a pas été farté.
Je vais déposer quelques gouttes d'eau.
Et puis on va essayer maintenant,
sur le ski qui a été farté.
Il est encore un petit peu chaud.
Et regardez bien la différence.
Sur le ski non farté, l'eau s'étale.
Il y a beaucoup de contact entre l'eau
et la semelle du ski.
Sur le ski qui a été farté, eh bien,
l'eau forme une bille bien ronde.
Il y a très peu de contact entre l'eau
et la semelle du ski.
Par conséquent, l'eau va mieux circuler
sur la semelle qui a été fartée
que sur celle qui ne l'a pas été.
Regardez.
- C'est net !
- Clairement.
Ouh là, le temps passe.
J'ai rendez vous avec William
et ses chiens de traîneau
et je crois bien que je suis à la traîne.
Est-ce que je peux récupérer
tes skis pour les refaire ?
Oui, ils en ont besoin.
- Ça va ?
- Bonjour William !
Bonjour Jamy !
Alors tu fais du stop ?
Ben oui, et il n'y a pas trop de passage,
y'a une place pour moi ?
Il y a une place pour toi sur le côté là.
- Ok !
- Tu vas mettre les deux pieds sur le patin de droite
et tu mets bien tes deux mains sur le guidon.
- Comme ceci ?
- Voilà.
- Allez !
- Il faut bien se tenir au départ.
Oui, on a tendance à basculer sur l'arrière.
Alors moi, je vais diriger Mouze là, c'est mon chien de tête.
Il va prendre les directions que je vais lui donner.
Donc à la voix.
Droite ! Droite !
Et je vais m'occuper aussi du freinage par contre, je vais te demander, voilà, dans des virages
à droite, on se penche à droite, dans
les virages à gauche, on se penche à gauche.
Alors ce qui surprend toujours quand on est sur
un traîneau comme ça, il n'y a pas de rêne ?
Non, il y a aucune rêne, aucune guide.
Tout se fait à la voix et même le guidon
qu'on appelle le guidon, cette barre, là.
Ce n'est pas un guidon comme un vélo où
on peut tourner de droite et de gauche.
C'est vraiment les chiens, l'attelage qui va t'amener le traîneau dans la bonne direction.
On n'est pas obligé d'hurler parce qu'ils
ont une très bonne ouïe en fait.
Ce n'est pas forcément le mot
qui va être important, c'est l'intonation.
Qu'est-ce que c'est comme race ?
Alors là, on est sur de l'Alaskan husky.
C'est une race qui nous vient d'Alaska.
C'est en fait le chien de Jack London, c'est Croc-Blanc.
Donc c'est du chien indien d'Alaska
qui a été mélangé un petit peu avec du loup et du coyote.
Donc là, il va y avoir une petite montée.
- On va aider un peu ?
- On va les aider, soit en patinant
et des fois on arrive même en marchant pour les soulager
parce que c'est de la poudreuse.
- Attention au saut !
- Wow !
Ça va les chiens ?
Alors on a souvent tendance à s'apitoyer sur le sort de ces chiens.
Tirer un traîneau de près de 200 kg à longueur de journée, on se dit que ça ne doit pas être facile.
Eh bien on se trompe, c'est une idée reçue.
D'abord parce que ces chiens sont de véritables athlètes.
Ils s'entraînent.
Au passage, je vous déconseille
d'adopter ce genre de chiens
si vous ne pouvez pas le faire courir
15 à 20 kilomètres par jour.
Ensuite, parce qu'au final, ces chiens
ne tirent qu'une toute petite charge.
Je vais vous montrer.
Le poids, c'est une force verticale
qui est dirigée vers le bas.
Alors, en temps normal, elle s'exprime en newtons.
Mais nous, pour mieux comprendre,
on va parler en kilogrammes.
Le traîneau qui est juste derrière vous, les enfants,
pèse, allez on va dire une petite vingtaine de kilos, d'accord ?
On va rajouter du poids, il me faut des passagers.
Tu pèses combien ?
23 kilos !
23 kilos avec l'équipement,
on va dire 25 kilos. Allez !
Deuxième passager, ça fait 50 kilos.
Et toi, voilà on est à 75 kg.
- Comment s'appelle votre maîtresse ?
- Agnès.
Vous allez jouer le rôle du musher.
Je ne vous demande pas votre poids,
mais on va dire que grosso modo,
passagers plus musher, plus traineau,
on arrive grosso modo à 150 kg.
Et pourtant le traîneau ne s'enfonce pas.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que le sol exerce lui aussi
une force
dans la direction opposée, vers le haut
et une force équivalente.
Par conséquent, les deux forces s'annulent.
Les chiens ne doivent donc vaincre
que la force de frottement entre le traîneau et la neige.
Et pour mesurer cette force,
eh bien je vais utiliser un peson.
Et maintenant, je vais commencer à tirer.
Je mets en tension.
Voilà pour le moment, on est à 3 kilos
et je tire.
Allez, c'est parti, c'est moi qui fais les chiens. Alors, je suis à combien ?
8 kilos, 9 kilos, 10 kilos, 8 kilos.
Le traineau pèse 150 kg
et il ne faut qu'une force de 8 kg
pour le déplacer.
S'il y a 10 chiens, chaque chien va devoir tirer 800 grammes.
Franchement, ce n'est pas énorme.
Allez je vous laisse aller essayer
le traîneau tiré par les chiens.
Alors j'ai jeté un œil sur le programme
des activités de la semaine.
Ils ne vont pas chômer les enfants.
Moi qui pensais profiter du soleil en terrasse en dégustant des produits du terroir.
Eh bien, ça se mérite.
Au programme des festivités,
en plus du traîneau
tiré par les chiens,
il y a une sortie raquettes.
Et en fin de semaine,
la construction d'un igloo.
Je vais prendre un peu d'avance,
histoire de voir à quoi il faut s'attendre.
Ah, c'est agréable.
Ah, les raquettes !
On a plein d'a priori
sur ce mode de locomotion.
On s'imagine que ça manque de fun.
Eh bien, on se trompe. Avec des raquettes,
on est libre, on peut aller
où l'on veut. Découvrir la montagne comme on le sent.
Attention quand même hein.
Si vous vous éloignez
des sentiers balisés,
mieux vaut être accompagné
par un professionnel comme Didier
qui m'attend,
accompagnateur en montagne.
Bon ça va, tout le monde ne m'a pas abandonné.
- Bonjour Didier.
- Bonjour Jamy.
Qu'est-ce que tu regardes ?
Ah bah je regarde d'un peu plus près
cette piste laissée par un animal.
Tu as une petite idée de l'animal
concerné ?
Non, je ne suis pas du coin.
Alors première chose à observer,
est-ce que tu distingues
au fond de l'empreinte un dessin ?
Qui te ferait penser à des coussinets, un sabot.
Pas forcément, hein.
Donc, en fonction de la texture
de la neige, il n'est pas toujours facile
de voir ce fameux dessin au fond de l'empreinte.
Mais on va avoir d'autres indices.
Là, si tu regardes bien,
on voit que les quatre
trous laissés par les quatre pattes
n'ont pas forcément la même taille.
Ça veut donc dire que c'est un animal
à quatre pattes ?
Tu as un autre renseignement
tout de suite.
C'est qu'entre ce regroupement de quatre pattes
et ce regroupement de quatre pattes-là, l'animal, il a fait un bond.
Un lapin, un lièvre ?
Les lapins, en règle générale, on les trouvera pas au-dessus de 600 mètres d'altitude.
D'accord.
Et l'altitude où nous sommes là,
un peu plus de 1 600 mètres d'altitude.
OK, donc c'est un lièvre et donc on en
conclut qu'il allait dans cette direction.
Eh ben non, Jamy.
- Justement, je t'explique.
- Très bien.
Tu vois mes bâtons ?
- Ouais.
- C'est mes deux pattes avant.
D'accord, mes deux pieds chaussés
de raquettes, ce sont mes pattes arrières.
Lorsque le lièvre fait un bond,
ces pattes-là vont passer devant.
Et est-ce qu'il t'arrive de croiser des animaux ?
Ah oui, Jamy. Le Vercors, c'est très sauvage.
Mais tu croises qui ou quoi ?
Alors mes plus belles rencontres,
c'est certainement celles avec les loups.
Tu as vu des loups ?
Oui, je les ai croisés sept fois
depuis que je suis dans le Vercors.
Sept fois en 23 ans.
Quoi d'autre ?
Alors le Vercors est très diversifié.
Il offre des gorges, des plateaux,
des prairies.
Ça veut dire beaucoup d'espèces.
Allez vas-y, mets nous en appétit, là.
Alors on pourrait parler du cerf.
Des cerfs, et il t'arrive de trouver des bois ?
J'ai ça dans mon sac, alors celui-ci est un petit bois de cerf.
Alors c'est tout une science
l'étude des bois de cerf.
On pourrait parler rien que de ce bois pendant longtemps.
Mais on sait à peu près quel âge il a celui-ci ?
Celui-ci, moi je dirais troisième ou quatrième année.
- On continue ?
- On continue.
Nous y voilà.
Que c'est beau, ça nettoie les yeux.
Tu comprends Jamy pourquoi
j'ai choisi de faire ce métier.
Merci de m'avoir entraîné jusqu'ici.
Et merci, je le dis pour les enfants
et les enseignants que tu amènes jusqu'ici
parce que vraiment, ça donne envie d'aimer tous ces paysages.
On a toute la chaîne des Alpes du Nord,
avec le Mont-Blanc
et au premier plan devant nous,
la sœur jumelle du Vercors,
le massif de la Chartreuse.
- Ici là ?
- Juste devant nous.
Ouais, on voit bien le massif calcaire.
- Et puis derrière la chaîne de Belledonne.
- Exactement.
C'est vraiment chouette d'avoir ça dans le Vercors
et de pouvoir emmener
surtout des enfants ici.
Je pourrais rester ici pendant des heures.
Mais bon, on a un igloo à construire
encore.
- D'ailleurs Jamy, si on y allait ?
- On y va, allez !
Faudrait peut être qu'on songe à faire notre igloo.
Bon, ben je te propose de s'installer par ici Jamy.
Ça me semble être un bon endroit
pour construire un igloo.
Qu'est-ce qui te dit que c'est le bon coin ?
L'épaisseur du manteau neigeux mais
ce que je te propose c'est de vérifier ensemble
l'épaisseur qu'on a là tout de suite.
OK, allons-y.
Donc tant que ça descend, c'est
qu'on est encore dans la neige.
Là, tu vois, ça résiste, si tu veux essayer.
- Ouais, ça butte.
- Donc là, on va prendre un petit point de repère.
Vas-y retire la.
- Ok.
Et donc là, on a assez de neige ?
Pour pouvoir faire une fosse à froid. Il va falloir qu'on ait un petit peu plus d'épaisseur.
Donc on va rajouter de la neige,
on va faire un dôme avant toute chose.
D'accord, alors quand on parle de l'igloo, on a tous en tête
les igloos qui sont fabriqués par les Inuits.
Là, ils utilisent des
des blocs de neige tassée.
Ce n'est pas exactement ce qu'on va faire.
Ici, le manteau neigeux, la texture de la neige
va nous emmener vers une autre technique de survie pour la construction d'igloo,
qui est la technique norvégienne.
Et voici la recette d'un igloo
à la norvégienne.
Pour cela, il nous faut une pelle
et des sacs à dos vides,
qu'on va remplir de neige.
Je commence par un petit sac.
En même temps, les petits,
c'est pas les plus simples.
Ah, tu les fermes quand même ?
Oui, parce que si tu les fermes
pas la neige,
elle va partir quand tu vas les poser
et quand on va tasser dessus.
- Il faut bien les fermer.
- Alors il faut que je les ferme.
Ensuite, tracer un cercle, c'est
à l'intérieur qu'on va bâtir l'igloo.
C'est juste pour délimiter.
C'est un point de repère par expérience pour nous.
Et maintenant, le plus dur commence.
Comme il n'y a pas assez d'épaisseur
de neige, 50 cm, on va en rajouter.
Alors on va faire une base large, pour
pouvoir après monter jusqu'à au moins 1m20.
Une épaisseur indispensable pour construire,
vous le verrez plus tard, une fosse à froid.
Alors c'est important
de bien tasser la neige.
Pour changer sa texture.
- C'est à dire qu'on va la faire durcir un petit peu ?
- C'est ça.
La température descend.
On est à quelle hauteur là ?
On a un bon mètre 40 je pense.
C'est sur ce dôme de neige que l'on va maintenant poser les sacs à dos.
Mais attention, pas n'importe comment.
Alors juste une chose très importante,
ça, c'est par expérience.
Toujours les sangles du sac
vers le bas pour pouvoir les tirer
facilement par en dessous.
OK, compris.
Et en fait, pour bien comprendre
ces sacs-là, ils vont former le début de l'habitacle.
Exactement le début de la voûte.
Très bien.
- Donc on va les recouvrir ?
- On va les recouvrir complètement de neige.
Et pour cela il faut un accessoire
indispensable : une couverture.
- Comme ça, c'est pas trop mal.
- C'est bon pour toi ?
- Alors là, il y a un bout qui dépasse.
- Alors rebique-le un peu sous les sacs.
Sinon, ça va faire un point d'ancrage mort et on n'arrivera pas à retirer les sacs ni la couverture.
- Ok, je les borde.
- Exactement.
On a sollicité quelques Epicurieuses et Epicurieux qui faisaient du ski dans le coin.
Ils ont eu pitié de nous. Ça va les Epicurieux ?
- Ouais !
- Ils sont un peu essoufflés.
Bon Didier, ça y est, on est à nouveau seul.
Ils nous ont abandonnés.
En même temps, valait mieux parce que je ne sais pas s'il y aurait eu de la place pour tout le monde.
Alors maintenant, Jamy une fois
qu'on a recouvert tout ça, il va falloir
qu'on creuse en dessous des sacs à dos.
Attention, c'est l'une des étapes les plus délicates.
Il faut d'abord creuser l'entrée de l'igloo,
puis enlever progressivement
la neige à l'intérieur.
Alors à quoi ça ressemble à l'intérieur ?
On a bien bossé, hein.
- T'as vu on a bien tassé tout ça !
- Peut-être un peu trop.
Donc maintenant, il n'y a plus qu'à espérer qu'en creusant,
ça ne s'écroule pas sur nos têtes alors je te rassure, ça m'est encore jamais arrivé.
- C'est un travail de mineur, là.
- T'as vu un petit peu.
Va falloir creuser là dessous.
Et en plus, il faut que tu parles fort parce que la neige, ça étouffe les bruits, hein.
- Tu m'entends Jamy ?
- Je t'entends, mais loin.
Faute de place, il ne peut y avoir
qu'une seule personne qui creuse.
Creuser, déblayer.
L'objectif : arriver à la verticale des sacs à dos.
Et là, maintenant, on est au niveau de la sonde.
- Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
- On continue de monter.
On va bientôt voir les sacs, enfin bientôt, à un moment, on verra les sacs.
Mais je pense qu'on peut remonter
encore de bien 50 ou 60 vers le haut.
Ok, ca marche.
- Je commence à enlever les sacs là ?
- Allez !
Jamy, tu vas retirer les sacs
et tu me les passes.
Alors tire-les délicatement un par un.
- Un par un ?
- Un par un.
Est-ce que tu en as vu un qu'il faut tirer en premier ?
Celui qui est face à toi, tu vas voir,
tu vas en avoir un tout de suite
devant toi. Tu peux le retirer.
- Ok, tout doucement ?
- Et puis après moi, je te le rattrape.
Faut que je me mettes sur le côté.
Deux d'un coup ! Encore dix Jamy !
- Et le dernier.
- Parfait.
Eh bien, ça y est, me voilà installé dans mon igloo, prêt pour la nuit.
Et vous pouvez me faire confiance, il y fait bon.
Enfin bon, meilleur qu'à l'extérieur.
Alors comment peut-on être protégé du froid,
dans une coquille de neige comme celle-ci ?
Eh bien, ce sont les petites bulles d'air
emprisonnées par la neige
qui nous protègent du froid,
qui nous isolent. Comme l'air,
prisonnier, entre les parois du double
ou du triple vitrage des fenêtres de nos maisons.
En fait, l'air empêche la chaleur
que les occupants de l'igloo
produisent d'être évacuée à l'extérieur.
Concrètement, c'est moi qui réchauffe
l'igloo.
Il fait combien à l'intérieur ?
Zéro degré, c'est beaucoup mieux
qu'à l'extérieur.
Là, en ce moment, il fait entre -9 et -10
et on annonce -14 pour la nuit.
Tiens, au passage, c'est pour cette raison que les Inuits
ne construisent pas leurs igloos
avec des pavés de glace.
La glace est dépourvue d'air,
elle n'est pas isolante.
Ils utilisent donc des pavés de neige
tassée.
Et lorsque celle-ci se transforme en glace, ils déménagent et construisent un nouvel igloo.
Ah, une dernière chose, l'architecture de l'igloo est très importante pour conserver
la chaleur, et notamment ce petit trou
que l'on a creusé à l'entrée de l'igloo.
Je vais vous montrer.
Vous voyez cette petite cavité
qu'on a creusée à l'entrée de l'igloo.
C'est ce que l'on appelle une fosse à froid.
L'air froid est plus dense que l'air chaud.
Il va donc s'accumuler dans cette fosse.
L'air chaud va s'élever au dessus.
L'air froid sert de bouchon et empêche
l'air chaud de partir vers l'extérieur.
Bon, je retourne à l'intérieur moi,
parce qu'il fait vraiment pas très chaud ici.
J'espère que cette journée à la montagne vous a plu, qu'elle vous a donné
des tas d'idées pour emmener vos élèves en classe de neige ici dans le Vercors,
pour retrouver Didier et William.
Ou dans un autre massif de la région
Auvergne-Rhône-Alpes,
en hiver, ce ne sont pas les destinations qui manquent.
Quant à moi, eh bien, je vais faire comme les marmottes,
je vais aller dormir dans mon igloo
et on se retrouve au printemps
pour observer ces fameuses
marmottes, justement.
A bientôt.
Je vais être bien.